Speaker 1: OK, today we're going to look at
a super interesting interview with a Republican
senator actually being forced to go beyond
the talking points when questioned by Fox
News host Chris Wallace.
It's really easy to simply say, you know,
we can increase the deficit.
We don't have the money for things Democrats
want to do.
Where is the money going to come from now?
Of course, we know that they never asked those
questions.
When it's about defense spending or war or
tax cuts for the rich, we know about that
double standard.
But it doesn't matter because if they're not
questioned about those talking points, there
are lots of people who buy it.
Hey, yeah.
Billions, hundreds of billions.
That sounds crazy.
How do we afford this stuff?
And if they're not questioned about it, they
never really have to explain what they mean.
And you get a lot of Republican voters who
end up agreeing with you.
Now, similarly, when Republicans say Biden's
infrastructure plan is too expensive, it's
not all really infrastructure.
It's filled with crap.
When they say Biden's job plan is just spending
money we don't have, it's easy as long as
you never have to explain anything.
But when you do have to explain, well, OK,
which of these things would you cut?
Which of these are not worthy elements for
this plan?
Something interesting happens.
First of all, they almost never have actual
answers.
And secondly, it throws them off so badly
that they often end up exposing other garbage
talking points that they also typically are
allowed to get away with.
So let's dove right in.
This is Fox host Chris Wallace asking Republican
Senator Bill Cassidy.
All right, Senator.
Sir, which specific parts of the Biden jobs
plan would you cut?
There's workforce development, there's childcare,
you know, all these different elements of
it.
Cassidy has no answers and instead just starts
slamming teachers unions and it starts to
get pretty unhinged.
Take a look
Speaker 4: up on the screen.
One hundred billion dollars for workforce
development.
Four hundred billion dollars to care for the
elderly and disabled.
Two hundred and twenty five dollars billion
for child care.
And two hundred dollars billion for free preschool.
Senator.
Which of those programs that I just put up,
which are those programs do you think people
in your state don't need?
Every one of those programs should be evaluated
if it's important.
It should be advanced, it's not infrastructure.
When people say, wait a second, I like this
because we need a new bridge across the Calcasieu
River in Lake Charles.
I'm saying this plan will not give it to you.
The amount of spending for roads and bridges
is so low that and split between 50 states
over five years.
You're not going to get your bridge now.
We may need this, by the way.
We just are restarting our are bipartisan
working group to come out family support for
the dependent children and elderly.
But that is not going to give you a road and
bridge.
And that's what people in my state would really
like to see.
Speaker 1: OK, so so far, he doesn't say any
of the programs are bad, but he says they're
not infrastructure.
But again, this is a jobs plan.
They're all job related and they are, you
know, education, developing a workforce.
These are even, I would argue, parts of infrastructure
in the 21st century.
But then Cassidy says, well, this won't get
my constituents all the things they want.
This money is going to go to all 50 states.
That's not really a reason to oppose the bill
unless your expectation is that all the money
goes to your state.
But that's not how federal spending works.
And it's not infrastructure.
But again, it's a jobs bill.
So so far, this is the lightest questioning
in other countries.
You would be ridiculed as a journalist if
you didn't ask these questions.
And in the United States, with these unprepared
buffoons, just asking the obvious questions
gets you to a point of realizing this.
This guy doesn't know what he's talking about.
Let's continue.
Speaker 4: Yeah, but but I guess the question
is and, you know, we could argue and I have
back and forth with both sides about infrastructure,
but there are a lot of programs that are an
infrastructure.
And the question I'm asking you is, should
would you support the government paying for
them?
I mean, I looked into it in your state of
Louisiana, the the rate of child poverty is
twenty five percent.
One in four of the children in Louisiana are
in poverty.
And according to the White House, 42 percent
of residents in Louisiana do not have access
to two child care.
So don't they want wouldn't they benefit?
Forget whether it's infrastructure or not,
wouldn't they benefit from these government
programs?
So I don't know if they would.
If you think about the main driver of elevating
out of poverty is good education.
Now, what we saw in the pandemic was teachers
unions keeping schools shut.
Even when the Centers for Disease Control
said it was safe to go back.
The president wants to give universal pre-K
run by the same teachers unions.
Now, if you're in Chicago and there's more
money going to the school systems into the
unions, and yet they still won't open up.
Speaker 1: So he's asked specifically, child
poverty is a real problem in Louisiana.
Child poverty is a problem in the United States.
It's an even bigger problem in Louisiana.
And this bill helps child poverty.
Isn't that something to be glad that the bill
addresses?
Well, I don't know, says Asgharzadeh.
Teachers unions forced schools to close during
the pandemic zero substantive engagement with
the topics at hand, and then it continues
to just be an alternate reality.
Wallace shows Kassidy, you know, the Trump
tax cuts you supported.
Speaking of spending, those tax cuts disproportionately
help the rich and they increase the deficit,
which he claims to be concerned about.
Now, when it's Joe Biden and Cassidy ignores
the substance and says, well, you know, unemployment
rates were really low before the pandemic.
Speaker 4: I want to take a look at those
tax cuts.
According to the Tax Policy Center, the average
first year tax cut for a household making
less than twenty five thousand dollars, the
average tax cut was just sixty dollars.
The average tax cut for a household making
three point four million dollars was one hundred
and ninety three thousand dollars.
And contrary to talk that it will pay for
itself, the Trump tax cuts are now projected
to add one and a half trillion dollars to
the deficit over 10 years.
Senator, of the two million tax filers in
Louisiana, only fourteen thousand of them
were paying more and filing gross income of
more than five hundred thousand dollars.
So what's wrong with raising the top tax rate
to where it was during the Bush 43 and Obama
administrations in order to help the working
and middle class?
If all you do is look at first degree facts,
Chris, you can make a point like that.
It sounds just like President Biden speaking,
speaking to Congress.
And I'm not accusing you.
I'm just pointing that out.
If you look at the overall effect, the aspiration
of this Biden administration is to return
to the economy.
We had before covid, where we had record low
unemployment, which means record high unemployment
for African-Americans, veterans, women, Hispanics,
the disabled.
Speaker 1: So after throwing in that shot
about, hey, Chris, you sound like Joe Biden
because you're asking real questions, Cassity
tries to argue that that deficit increase,
thanks to Trump's tax cuts, is only a first
order effect.
And then the second order effects would be
that the economy grows so much that the tax
cut pays for itself.
It simply didn't happen.
The deficit increase and then it increased
more and OK, then covid hit.
But we know that the tax cuts for the rich
are not revenue positive even in the long
term.
It's been studied for decades.
And then Cassity says as evidence, look at
job creation before the pandemic.
But after Trump's tax cuts, remember, once
again, job creation under Trump was just a
slightly slowed down continuation of what
we saw under Barack Obama slowdown.
His 2017 tax bill didn't go into effect until
2018, which was reflected in people's taxes
filed in 2019.
The timeline does not add up.
Let's look at just the last bit here.
And there does seem to be like a child crying
in the background during this piece that that's
not that's part of the clip.
Speaker 4: High school dropouts with wage
growth disproportionately in the lower and
lower quintiles of the income structure.
That's what we were seeing, the economy really
help.
Now, that was all part of the Tax Cut and
Jobs Act, Bill.
You can't separate them.
And so if you want to say, my gosh, these
people are making more money, why don't we
return and keep the tax cut and Jobs Act?
That's that's the flip side of the question
you're asking.
And I think that flip side is the part that
should be emphasized.
But the argument is and there certainly is
some data to indicate that the Trump tax cuts
benefited the wealthy and corporations more
than they did the working and middle class.
Speaker 1: Chris Wallace is trying, but this
is simply going nowhere.
They do not have answers for any of this.
They simply move on to something else.
Which programs would you cut?
Doesn't say, but bashes teachers unions.
Teachers unions are bad.
Well, what about the deficit?
Oh, yeah, but job creation in 2017 was really
great.
It's pathetic.
And they should be subjected to this type
of questioning in every interview.
My sense is, if this became the standard on
Fox News, a lot of these officials would stop
doing Fox News interviews.
And indeed, my understanding is that there
are increasingly Republicans who are turning
down interviews with Chris Wallace because
he's just asking basic questions that any
reporter in just about every country would
be expected to ask.
They fall apart.
The talking points never made sense.
But if there's no pushback, in fact, sometimes
it's not that there isn't pushback from the
hosts.
It's they cheerlead.
They all right.
Of course.
Yeah, right.
Right.
Yeah, but Democrats don't.
Don't understand that, but yes, of course
you're right, Senator, as soon as there's
basic push back, they fall apart.
We'll have more examples like this on our
Instagram page, which you can follow at David
Pakman show.
The great Daniel Goleman will be joining me
after this short break.
Really looking forward to this interview